feels like my skulls on fire I'm good or
fire lots of fire alright guys well
Keanu Reeves is now rumored to be ghost
writer and Doctor Strange two multiverse
of madness among all the talks of Keanu
Reeves being in the MCU this actually
sounds like a really great fit we're
gonna watch the video from the cosmic
Wonder our great friend Warren who by
the way if you guys haven't seen the
video yet we did a fan tastic for
discussion with the guy right here on
this channel there's a link in the
description box linked in the pin
comment for you guys to go check that
out
Oren is great on getting the down low
and all the hottest takes and the
hottest rumors going around a lot of
time in being right so let's see what he
has to say for this one how's it going
everybody it's Warren welcome back to my
channel to cosmic wonder where we talk
about all things relating to Marvel and
of course the MCU
now even though unfortunately due to the
coronavirus Marvel has had to adjust
their schedule a little bit and delay
some upcoming productions as well
however nothing is going to fully stop
Marvel from eventually releasing all of
their kids never stopped we're going to
talk about something that I know many
fans have been waiting for for a very
long time Ghost Rider in the MCU and not
only the possibility of Ghost Rider
entering the MCU but him entering in
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness and possibly Keanu Reeves
playing the part hey be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating clutters you
answered canon i giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm taking a
winner at five hundred fifty thousand
subscribers now obviously this is super
exciting and news
Ghost Rider coming to the MCU but what
is really interesting is where this
report is coming from you all may
remember the Twitter account Roger at
Ward L he's the person that leaked a ton
of information about Avengers endgame
all of which ended up being 100% true
literally every word he said we're
Avengers
endgame came out that was going to
happen happened and he's been quiet for
a while but a new account has Paseo as
in jail after Ward L at his collar with
the same name it's widely believed that
this is his new account and he was
locked out of his old one most likely
for leaking very accurate information
about the MCU and in his new report he
has tweeted return of the Darkhold will
be fundamental for upcoming asian
Captain Britain and Ghost Rider in
Doctor Strange 2 events of both the show
and movie will prepare the ground for
doctor dooms break this down piece by
piece starting with the Darkhold rv0
also known as the book of sins or the
book of spells is an ancient book of
spells and unspeakable power this book
was created a real photo matter from
hell it is said to contain infinite
knowledge and over the course of history
in the comics many people have searched
for it including Red Skull Daniel
Whitehall and Nick Fury himself now the
very interesting part about the
fundamental for the upcoming one
division series and based off of
everything that we know there is going
to be a connection to it we know that
the one division series is going to
explore more of the actual Scarlet Witch
and her powers we also know that Agatha
Harkness is going to be in the one
division series as well and in the
comics she's an actual witch who helps
and trains Wanda and it's pretty much
all but confirmed that this is the
character that Kathryn Hahn is going to
be playing in the series not to mention
we also have some leaked photos of the
one division series of the Salem witches
so in this series they're going to
explore more of Wanda as a witch there's
going to be actual spells and as you can
see there will be other witches in this
series as well which means one of them
will most likely have the dark hold or
mephesto the ruler of the Hell dimension
himself could even make an appearance
after all he is deeply connected to
Doctor Doom but more about that when we
talk about Doctor Doom the next part of
this report says Captain Britain and
ghost
and dr. strange too is something that
fans have been predicting and wanting
for a pretty long time especially if dr.
strange too is going to explore more of
the mystic side now most people know
that there are many different versions
of Ghost Rider but for this sake we're
going to be talking about Johnny Blaze
and the reason for that is because of
the connection with mephesto in order to
save the life of his father stunt
motorcyclist Johnny Blaze agreed to give
his soul to Satan who of course was
later revealed to be an arch demon named
mephesto this turned him into the
supernatural Ghost Rider
now Johnny blazes Ghost Rider is widely
believed to be one of the most powerful
Marvel characters ever created in fact
in the world war hulk series it was
stated by Doctor Strange himself that
Ghost Rider might be equally as powerful
as the green scarf persona of Hulk and
could possibly defeat him and now it
seems like he's going to be making his
official MCO debut in multiverse of
madness which is something that Kevin
Feige has briefly hinted at in an
interview a few months ago when he was
speaking about Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness he did mention
that we are going to be getting a new
character and this is what he said in
the interview sometimes you're choosing
a title hero choosing which main
character or main team you want to bring
to the screen and oftentimes it's as
you're making and developing the movie
asking who will come into it and who
will fit into it the next Doctor Strange
film for instance features some new MCU
characters which will be making their
debut in that movie you won't expect or
won't guess who it is but we found a
cool way to make it work because we want
to make a particular type of movie there
and there was a character who we always
wanted to do something with who will fit
really well there Oh Marvel Studios
Kevin Feige and it sounds like the way
that they're going to make this
character work is perhaps through one
division and the Darkhold it's very
clear that spells and witches are going
to be involved in the series but whether
or not mephesto is actually going to be
making an appearance is unknown yet
however it does seem to be going this
way although he may not be portrayed as
a Satan like figure but eventually
Johnny Blaze goes on for trade it's been
dog did demon this is right around dr.
Strange's alley as he normally deals
with extra-dimensional demon spirits and
deities
to vibe blaze and according to record el
it's going to happen now recently you
may have heard rumors that Keanu Reeves
is in talks to play ghostwriter a role
that I think many fans would definitely
be excited to see him play and we do
know that Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios
have been meeting with Keanu Reeves
about the perfect role for him to play
to finally get him in the MCU and Kevin
Feige has recently admitted this he said
that they meet with Keanu for every
movie that they make discussing every
possible character that he could play
unfortunately they haven't found the
perfect role for him yet which is why we
haven't seen him in the MCU but perhaps
they have found that perfect role with
Ghost Rider this is the same thing that
happened with Jake Gyllenhaal Kevin
Feige said that they met with him many
different times until they finally found
the role of Mysterio which was perfect
for him and then they cast him it sounds
like that may be the case for Keanu
Reeves and Ghost Rider and perhaps he
could be making his appearance and
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness then the account reported that
Captain Britain is going to be making
his debut in multiverse of madness was
actually expected that Captain Britain
could make his MCU debut as spider-man
apart from a man because they mentioned
the multiverse for those of you who do
not know Captain Britain has a very deep
connection to the multiverse his real
name is Brian Braddock we all getting
into a motorcycle accident Merlin the
great magician and his daughter Roma
appeared to him and offer him the
opportunity to become a captain Britain
he takes the responsibility in Roma and
Merlin grant him the powers and also the
responsibility of protecting Britain in
the earth-616 universe or the main
Marvel Comics universe he would later go
on to find out that he was part of the
Captain Britain Corps the Captain
Britain core consists of other Captain
Britain's from other universes and
collectively they are responsible for
protecting the multiverse and since
spider-man far from home name-dropped
multiverse we all thought that he was
going to appear however we know that
Mysterio was lying and make lips that is
all changed now thanks to dr. strange in
the multiverse of madness we know that
the multiverse is very real and is
coming and not to mention there was a
major Easter Egg for Captain Britain in
Avengers endgame when Tony and Steve
Rogers go back in time to camp Lehi or
the birthplace of Captain America Steve
is trying to avoid being spotted and in
order
do that he hides in a random office of
course this turns out to be the office
of Peggy Carter and he ends up spotting
her through the window of the office
speaking with another agent it was a
very heartfelt moment which made people
not really pay attention to the
conversation that was being had between
Peggy and the other agent but in this
conversation Peggy Carter mentioned
something about someone named Braddock
who hasn't checked in yet now due to the
fact that it's probably not referring to
Bryan Braddock but most likely referring
to his father his father Sir James and
mother Lady Elizabeth worked in a
laboratory when there was an accidental
Severson madness
so in Avengers in game they name-drop
Braddock a Captain Britain Easter Egg
and then in the very next MCU film
spider-man far from home they teased the
multiverse now of course the multiverse
wasn't really involved but now we have
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness which will introduce the true
multiverse and according to this report
will also introduce Captain Britain and
clearly this lines up and makes a ton of
sense because if the multiverse is going
to be involved the Captain Britain Corps
is most likely going to be involved as
well and then the final report from this
account is that Doctor Doom will
eventually be introduced as well and the
events that take place in the one
division out of everybody seems to have
a connection to here and that is
mephesto Victor Von Doom aka dr. Jim's
mother Cynthia Von Doom was a very
talented witch she was a good person who
tried to protect her people but due to
being tricked by mephesto ends up being
locked in hell this leads to Doctor Doom
making a deal with mephesto not if he
can defeat him he'll let his mother go
dr. doom has yet to defeat mephesto
this movie's gonna be about Cynthia Von
Doom to her plane sometimes enabling
contact between Victor Von Doom and his
mother it's widely believed that Cynthia
Von Doom is going to be introduced
during the Salem witch trials in one
division and since it's likely that the
Dark hold and mephesto are going to be
introduced during that series as well or
Doctor Strange and multiverse of madness
it seems like Cynthia Vaughn do
we'll end up being stuck in one of my
festas realms this will undoubtedly lead
to the introduction of Victor Von Doom
Cinthia son who of course will later go
on to become Doctor Doom not to mention
that the Fantastic Four are getting
their own movie as well very soon and
Doctor Doom is a classic Fantastic Four
villain but Doctor Doom is one of the
greatest Marvel villains of all time so
his role will no doubt be much larger
than just a fantastic four villain he
will no doubt be warned of the big bads
that is coming to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so let me know what you think
about this report let me know what you
think about Ghost Rider and the fact
that Keanu Reeves could be playing him
Captain Britain and Victor Von Doom
be sure to comment down below and like
this also don't forget to subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to Marvel
and the MCU for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof well done it's so crazy
hearing about all this information of
what could possibly come from multiverse
of madness in particular with one
division combined we can't forget about
that show it seems like everything we're
hearing that could possibly come from it
are setting up a whole bunch of other
things and we're not really hearing too
many reports or high speculation about
what the actual plots of them are going
to be it's like we've heard some things
but we haven't really heard it fully I
guess the one thing that's been slightly
concerning is if any of this is true or
even half of it well with all the lore
that goes into all these characters how
much seed planting is there gonna be
involved in all of this because as cool
as like Captain Britain Doctor Doom
Salem witch trials getting involved
Ghost Rider all that being infused into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
sounds grand that sounds great but I
don't want overload of information it's
like the benefit of setting up these
characters are introducing them or
planting the seeds is the fact that
you'll have a multiple episode series of
blonde division and then you'll have a
movie Doctor Strange two multiverse of
madness it's not all gonna be like jam
packed into one film you know because
it's multiverse of madness I feel
that opens up a lot of room for
speculation you call multiverse you
could pretty much nobody went in there
you go you can speculate how this
character could be introduced and how
this character could mean you just put
Batman in these really you just
introduce anyone because of the fact
that it's multiverse right every single
rumor has to be taken with a grain of
salt I'm not familiar with this person
that warrant is specifically
name-dropping here that could lens
tongue I love the idea of these
characters coming into play I mean Keanu
Reeves as Ghost Rider
does sound awesome I mean that seems
like the main things are here and be
rumored for our Wolverine Silver Surfer
and Ghost Rider I personally think that
out of all those three characters Ghost
Rider would be the best fit for him
because Silver Surfer you know I
actually like briefly talked about this
in that video we do have warned yeah I
can I think he could bring in the body
language and the voice and everything
but you know he's he's primarily covered
up he's MO camped this is so I think we
want to see his face and while Johnny
Blaze would be in go in go stratiform
he'd be a skull a lot of time he's not
in the skull format I feel like the
personality of Johnny Blaze with having
a bit of that brooding dark side to him
but also cool guy with the bikes yeah I
think could be a great fit for Keanu
Reeves
I know Gabriel Luna was very much loved
for his work on agents of shield which I
know totally
oh my god brain farting right now but it
wasn't Johnny Blaze that he played who
was like I think no one Google search
away and I'm not gonna do it today I
think that'd be a great tease if you're
gonna allude to Doctor Doom first before
you even introduce the Fantastic Four
sort of edifying the the legacy of the
Doom family here man that'd be cool and
then Captain Britain sounds like with
you know DC working on their Green
Lantern a core Marvel will be somewhat
asleep working on their captain burning
core world protectors of the universe
and the multiverse all that does sound
good I just hope it's not over stuff
that and that at the end of the day that
we still get a stronghold and focus on
these characters and their actual
journeys like I want the thing that
multiversal madness has been exciting
before is not Doctor Strange at all it's
been exciting me for the multiverse a
you know
and that's what I want to check out like
Wanda vision I'm excited for it seen
more of the which side of Wanda if
anything at the Easter eggs I love what
he pointed out with endgame
name-dropping burden because I never
picked up on that but some teases of
those seeds kind of planted I think
would be the best fit but then again
it's like if you imagine dr. strange of
the multiverse it could just be like a
quick glimpse of something whether it's
transporting through portals and
dimensions and stuff if you slow down
you see him yeah it could be something
like that
John Lots uh I mean this information is
really exciting very good subscribe to
the real rejects these rumors lately
have been getting me rather excited I
mean the cool thing and the scary thing
both is that I think that in this new
phase Marvel has kind of something to
prove again endgame was such a
culmination obviously that they're going
to have to lay out new groundwork and
all this stuff sounds really exciting
I like the idea that the shows and the
movies are gonna interact and I'm pretty
much with you I don't want it to all
become spider-man 3 where there's a ton
of stuff packed in I think yeah bringing
in dr. Doom's mother's story into
especially Wanda vision would be a cool
thing somebody commented on that last
collab we do with cosmic Wonder I never
really found a role in my head for Keanu
and when somebody said ghost ride I was
like oh this is perfect like yeah
especially because yeah you'd be coming
off of Nick Cage who's already a meme
and I feel like jumping from Nick Cage
to Keanu is almost grounding it a little
bit more but while still remaining
larger-than-life and I feel like yeah
that is a character that you can get you
don't need to get an unknown actor
necessarily for I feel like Ghost Rider
has a larger-than-life miss that carries
that character more so than some of the
other ones I'm concerned in a sense
because I don't fully trust when they
say that certain movies are going to be
this genre or that genre but what I like
hearing about the new phase of the MCU
is that it sounds like we're gonna be
getting a lot of the magic hellish stuff
they've already said the cosmic stuff
but those seem like the two new flavors
is like the the hellish horror side and
then the cosmics
I've actually recently been playing God
of War one thing that I was really
dawning on me well the amount of time
they like name-drop Thor explore Norse
and Greek mythology in that franchise
door being part of Norse mythology
I remember how cool it was when they
felt like we were really exploring that
and we haven't really done its
come more of a sci-fi space movie with
Thor and less of like really
capitalizing on the Norse mythology side
of it and Lord of the Rings eNOS of it
yeah and I think if we can get it back
or reel in a little bit more maybe not
necessarily Norse mythology but kind of
like that mythology we're all familiar
with a certain degree even if we've only
heard glimpses of it in our lifetime a
little bit of like religious stuff I
like getting involved in the
groundedness of real historical events
like the Salem witch trials which has
had so many stories surrounding it and
that was a real life of historical event
I think it'd be cool to like really
infuse all these different things that
we've heard over the years of growing up
in the world and infuse it into the MCU
and yeah so it's like the multiverse
seems like their ticket into expanding
the universe obviously I'm looking
forward to the day when we can hear a
little bit more I can imagine that's why
maybe Scott Derrickson probably didn't
even want to do multiverse amanda says
it seems that they're really using both
Millan division and multiverse and man
has to be there groundwork to change the
universe and it's like they're they're
like big train station where everyone's
gonna go through yeah into their own
separate world it seems like it's gonna
be a lot more working from the top down
as opposed to letting the director do
what he wants to do anyway this is a
great video Thank You Warren so much for
putting this together subscribe to the
cosmic Wonder once he hits 5 50k
subscribers he will be given away a
Playstation and an Xbox but original
Xbox and a PlayStation 1 so you know if
you don't have those systems if you
threw them away you'll be replacing that
for you
horrible Fantastic Four Talk video and
our Wolverine fan cast yes well on his
channel subscribe to the rejects click
the notification bell
let's end this with a Michael B again it
was his birthday a few days ago yeah
Michael just wanted to say happy
birthday to you I hope Samantha sticks a
finger and you happy birthday to you
hope she sense a new peace happy
birthday dear Michael happy person
you know what to do you always know how
to give the best couple of us oh yeah
that's your birthday present buddy check
out his channel Omni media